hello I am I am Italian and
I invite apple it's been more than
now that I take people from 16
divers
I taught him a lot with the
fishmonger
I learned Landes luck a
victory over braga whose gift and
humanist he does not want  nor young tim
franke reform with two other workhorses
at the breeding pane fishing is
prohibited hedman leader
swedish portuguese russian and go no
chinese is now i will
teach you the caller why did
i choose at these mines  because to
sign this for complete it is not
about the student
but as the name assimilates suggests it
is about assimilating the man in a
progressive way and assimilates offers an
excellent possibility of discovering
and learning  a language in a
progressive and natural way there are
grammatical explanations they are
not far away there are explanations of
phonetics
but they are drunk and sound elegant and
all that allows you to wait to
start learning the language of  brilliant way
that's the reason why i
advise semi autonomous there are all the
people asking me how did
you do to learn so many
languages
you can find videos on
youtube
back
with me who speaks several languages ​​of
his  genre that describes the
learning process how I
learned them
precisely with a otherwise thank you all goodbye